on passe au palais de politique que ce
soit avec Chantal Hébert Michel David et
Stéphanie Gramont bonsoir à vous trois
bonsoir bonsoir On va commencer d'abord
par ce passage de François Legault à
Rouyn-Noranda finalement il y aura
attendu au jour 33 de la campagne pour
s'y rendre alors que c'est un dossier
qui occupé beaucoup l'attention
médiatique pendant l'été vous me direz
que c'est un moment tranquille les gens
qui ont moins les nouvelles les joints
les journaux pendant ce temps-là mais
sur toute cette histoire de
contamination avec la fonderie hard
monsieur le goût a rencontré des élus
municipaux nous a appris que les
négociations avec la fonderie ben c'est
toujours en cours pour arriver à réduire
les émissions à 15 nanogrammes d'ici 5
ans il n'exclut pas un référendum sur la
question parce qu'il veut relancer la
balle dans le camp des citoyens
maintenant on va l'écouter
c'est pas à moi prendre la décision tu
es aux citoyen de rouen-noranda il y a
deux scénarios scénarios c'est d'avoir
un plan qui est acceptable à population
qui respecte la santé qui respecte
l'environnement et de l'autre côté c'est
une fermeture d'usine la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre on nous a dit ce matin
dans une usine qu'on a visité qu'il y
avait il manquait du monde est-ce que ce
sera un drame économique de fermer la
fonderie hordes
il y a 650 emplois à 100000 dollars par
année je pense pas que 650 en haute
emploi disponible à 100 000 par année
donc il y a une décision économique à
prendre pour tout le monde aussi
on connaît même si on n'y est pas un peu
le climat le qui règne actuellement à
juan-noranda société qui est divisée sur
cette question là des gens des parents
d'abord des médecins aussi qui sont
inquiets pour la santé des gens chantant
je commençais avec vous ce qui prend la
bonne approche dans le dossier monsieur
LEGO
pour une femme campagne électorale c'est
tout de même particulier surtout que
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je pense que la
plupart des gens qui regardaient ça
là-bas ou ici pensez que le fardeau de
la preuve était encore dans la cour de
la fonderie qui on avait demandé de
refaire ses devoirs est-ce que monsieur
Legault a fait aujourd'hui c'est dire
ben non à la fin de faire d'autres la
preuve va être avec les gens qui vivent
dans la circonscription et qui devront
décider s'ils veulent sacrifier des
emplois
je suis pas sûr qu'il y a aidé son
candidat ou dans cette circonscription
là on verra on a vraiment l'impression à
Chantal qui l'oppose ici des bons
emplois payants puis on sait pourtant à
quel point c'est cher à ses yeux et la
santé publique mais la santé publique ça
fait quand même deux ans et demi qui
nous en parle avec la pandémie puis qui
nous montre que c'est important pour lui
et le soudainement ça pèse pas lourd
devant des emplois
et c'est une équation effectivement qui
détonne surtout quand il parle de
médecin en disant qui est un groupe de
médecins c'est pas eux qui vont décider
j'avoue que j'en dis pas moi les gens
qui vivent près de la fonderie et à qui
on présente ça comme ça dans la bouche
du Premier ministre parce que eux ça met
économie versus santé publique en
opposition et deux je suis pas convaincu
non plus que monsieur Legault quoi qu'il
dise voudrais vraiment élever des
enfants comme il le dit avec ce qu'il
considère comme acceptable aux yeux de
la santé publique Stéphanie est-ce qu'il
le risque est-ce que il peut donner
l'impression qu'il prend l'enjeu de
santé publique avec trop de légèreté
quand on présente ça comme un dilemme
entre est-ce qu'on va vers les emplois
où est-ce qu'on veut avoir des enfants
qui sont en santé c'est comme si on est
on met un pays sur qu'est-ce que ça vaut
un enfant qui est pas contaminé à
l'arsenic il y a quelque chose d'un peu
d'un peu terrible là-dedans maintenant
bon il y a peut-être d'autres solutions
et on l'a évoquait aussi de créer une
zone tampon de dire est-ce que on peut
réaménager le quartier qui est au pied
de l'usine ça s'est fait à malarticle où
on a on a carrément déménagé un quartier
parce qu'on voulait aménager une mine
d'or c'est peut-être c'est peut-être une
solution qui est pas nécessairement rose
non plus pour les gens qui vivent là
mais s'ils sont dédommagés
convenablement peut-être qu'il y a une
peut-être que c'est une piste qu'on
devrait explorer aussi effectivement
parce qu'à ce moment-là on pourrait dire
on respecte les normes parce que plus
personne qui vit à côté du lieu de la
contamination mais Michel il y a des
gens qui s'offusent qu'en disant
remettre ça des citoyens dans une
société qui est déjà divisée où ces
gens-là c'est eux qui vivent l'impact ça
manque de comment dire il manque de
leadership là-dedans le gouvernement
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez écoutez
c'est clair que monsieur Legault est en
rattrapage pendant tout l'été on a eu
l'impression que le gouvernement s'en
lavait les mains et puis là on a 4 jours
de l'élection monsieur le goût débarque
là c'est que je pense que c'est très
serré dans dans Rouen de randette
émission même et monsieur Legault ne
veut pas que l'élection soit un
référendum pour ou contre la fonderie
parce qu'à ce moment-là il y a des
chances de perdre tandis qu'en séparant
l'élection du référendum là les gens
font dire bon on peut quand même voter
pour laque somme toute un mauvais
gouvernement pour le reste mais quand
arrivera le référendum donc il nous
parle là on pourra exprimer notre
volonté dans notre opinion dans le
dossier de la de la fonderie alors je
trouve que c'est assez habile de la part
de monsieur Legault de dissocier c'est
les deux dossiers sur le fond ça change
pas l'appréciation qu'on peut faire de
la performance du gouvernement mais pour
le reste c'est quand ce monsieur le goût
disait écoutez voté pour l'ensemble de
mon bilan puis ça on va régler ça plus
tard
allez-y Chantal oui non mais sauf qu'une
question de temps et le temps
aujourd'hui était pas le temps de je
vais accompagner les gens dans un
cheminement qui s'annonce difficile
c'était c'est apprendre ou à laisser et
excuser le vocabulaire mais sacrément
patience on en reparlera après les
élections je suis pas convaincu moins
que si j'étais un parent dans cette
circonscription là je mettrai dit
l'ensemble de l'oeuvre de l'acaque est
pas suffire puis je vais lui faire
confiance pour ce qui arrive à la santé
on va parler dans une seconde du temps
on va revenir sur l'entrevue qu'il a
accordé à notre collègue qui est
animateur à la radio du matin là-bas
donnez-moi une seconde mais avant Michel
quand vous parlez de la tactique
politique derrière ça il reste quand
même qu'il essaie de définir son
adversaire qui est Québec solidaire en
l'occurrence ce député sortante et de
Québec solidaire en faisant eux Apple
c'est on va fermer l'usine monsieur
Gabriel Nadaud Dubois se retrouve aussi
dans une position où il doit défendre
lui la position de son parti en disant
nous on veut pas fermer l'usine on veut
que l'usine respecte la norme et
monsieur Legault oui mais son respect
que la norme techniquement on n'est pas
capable de se rendre à trois on va
arrêter à 15 on n'a pas ce que ça prend
sa n'existe pas descendre à trois
nanogrammes qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
de ça je pense que c'est ça la question
à laquelle les gens vont être obligés de
répondre je pense que techniquement
écoutez je prends un expert du tout en
fonderie mais il est fort possible que
ça rentre à trois nanogrammes ça coûte
la peau des fesses et que ça soit même
pas possible techniquement alors si
la question est de savoir est-ce qu'on
garde l'usine ouverte
où on la ferme si elle fait pas 3
nanogrammes je pense que oui la question
va finir par se poser dans ces termes-là
mais et Monsieur Nadaud Dubois je pense
va devoir assumer que c'est comme ça que
sont partis la voix donc parlons du
temps Chantal le soulignait tantôt ça
nous a tous surpris d'entendre ses
extraits qui ont même commencé à se
promener sur les réseaux sociaux de
cette entrevue que monsieur Legault a
accordé à l'animateur qui s'appelle
David Chabot sur les ondes de la radio
locale de Radio-Canada petite extrait
ici
vous parlez du de l'arsenic on a parlé
du 15 ans de grands en parlant de de
seuil ou c'est peut-être davantage
sécuritaire là je vais apaiser mes mots
mais aussi de l'acide sulfurique de
l'argent de l'arsenic du camion du
chrome du COBAL de la connaissez la
liste elle a encore vous vous c'est pas
exact que vous venez de dire vous venez
de dire davantage acceptable c'est pas
ce que la santé publique dit la santé
publique
non non la santé publique du pote
davantage
vous êtes des choses qui sont forts qui
sont pas d'accord avec vous
non Stéphanie réaction à ce genre
d'entrevue le ton monsieur Legault
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a tant que la
campagne se termine pour monsieur
Legault
il était depuis le début de la campagne
je trouve plutôt
assez puis dans les débats jamais donné
l'impression qu'il y avait vraiment
envie de
se faire questionner c'est sûr qu'il
était dans la position du du chef
sortant et qu'évidemment les quatre
autres parties lui envoyer des flèches
mais il y avait vraiment on donnait
vraiment l'impression d'être là avec
très peu de plaisir et quand on voit là
des répartis comme celle là on se dit ma
foi en plus de toutes les gars qui le
commisent lui-même durant la campagne
c'est tant que ça se termine Michel
à la santé publique des choses qu'elle
avait pas dites de façon aussi
catégorique encore là je pense que
l'accenté publique dit c'est sécuritaire
en attendant qu'on arrive à trois
nanogrammes
mais
précisément entendu que monsieur Legault
dit c'est sécuritaire alors non non il y
avait des nuances dans les propos de la
santé publique et d'autres parts quand
il s'agit des médecins c'est le même
François Legault que pendant la pandémie
souvenez-vous quand il y avait des
critiques à l'endroit de la gestion du
gouvernement qui est émise par des
médecins au bureau du premier ministre
oui mais ça c'est des militants à chaque
fois quelqu'un est pas d'accord avec
monsieur Legault c'est un militant non
la contrainte la contradiction devrait
le dire monsieur Legault a beaucoup de
mal avec ça et puis Chantal quand même
il y avait eu le temps de se préparer
pour centre-ville là il devait quand
même s'attendre à avoir ce genre de
questions surtout pour une radio locale
qui connaît très bien le tous les
dessous ce dossier là
parce que monsieur Legault jouait la
carte du personnage rassembleur pendant
à peu près l'ensemble de la pandémie
c'est ce qui lui avait valu une cote
supérieure à peu près n'importe quel
autre Premier ministre au Canada pour la
campagne électorale c'est comme si vous
voulez prévenir vous voyez moi je suis
pas vraiment cette personne là il y a la
mèche courte du début à la fin de la
campagne électorale ça commence le
premier jour et ça continue jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
point d'interrogation combien de plaisir
est-ce qu'il y a encore à faire ce
boulot de Premier ministre s'il trouve
ça si l'eau il y aurait eu tellement
d'autres façons surtout en fin de
campagne je vais vous dire moi je vais
couvert beaucoup de campagne électorales
dans beaucoup d'endroits généralement le
tongrincent c'est les gens qui perdent
mais j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un avec une
avance aussi confortable être aussi
grinçant en fin de campagne mais c'est
ce qui est top comment vous l'expliquez
vous avec le Messie que vous avez
mais je peux juste conclure qu'il est
fatigué et qu'il faut que la campagne
finisse stéphanie a complètement raison
et que d'autres parts il doit
certainement se voir aller et pas se
trouver très bon parlons d'immigrations
maintenant c'est un autre dossier qui le
mis dans l'eau chaude alors on se
rappelle la déclaration du ministre de
l'Immigration jean-boulé lors d'un débat
le débat c'était pas hier mais les
déclarations se sont retrouvées dans les
grands médias hier et c'est pour ça que
c'est un coup tout le monde s'en est
emparé puis ça forcée des réactions
alors je rappelle pour les gens qui
auraient manqué ça et il le dit dans le
débat monsieur boulet que 80% des
immigrants ils vont vivre à Montréal ils
parlent pas français ils travaillent pas
puis il y a des repas valeurs
québécoises mais il le balance c'est ça
très très rapidement alors aujourd'hui
on voit encore des réactions c'est
l'adversaire sont encore en train de
faire du village là dessus madame en
garde qui dit si je disqualifie
communiste de l'immigration pour un
prochain mandat comme Monsieur le Voulzy
pourquoi pourquoi il est encore en poste
parce que dans les fêtes il est encore
en poste de l'immigration monsieur James
tout de suite Stéphanie est-ce que ça le
met ça vraiment dans l'embarrasse qui
perd des plumes vraiment avec ça
monsieur le goût ben hyper plus que des
plumes au complet je parle de Monsieur
boulet là mais moi j'ai écouté ces
excuses aujourd'hui puis je trouve que
c'est pas tellement les excuses des
excuses du bout des lèvres en disant
j'aurais dû faire des nuances dire que
c'est seulement certaines personnes qui
qui parlent pas français certaines
personnes qui avaient pas aux valeurs
qui est aux valeurs québécoises
honnêtement c'est pas des nuances qui
aurait dû faire ce que dit c'est faux il
devrait mettre l'accent sur le sur le
beau côté de l'immigration à la place si
vraiment ministre de l'Immigration il
devrait dire mais ma foi les immigrants
c'est extraordinaire ils ont un salaire
qui est supérieur à celui des Québécois
de souche ils ont à peu près le même
taux de participation au marché du
travail donc on a toujours le sentiment
sur le dossier de l'immigration puis à
la fois le ministre et le Premier
ministre avec ses déclarations là sur le
fait que ce soit suicidaire etc on a
toujours le l'impression là qui voit ça
de façon négative et je pense que c'est
tout à fait nocif pour
la division de la population Michel
est-ce que vous avez un souvenir pendant
la campagne où il a été question
d'immigration du côté de monsieur
Legault sans qu'il ne se mettent dans
l'embarras pendant cette campagne non et
moi ça m'étonne que monsieur Legault a
décidé d'enfourcer ce cheval au début de
la campagne souvenez-vous le premier
jour Monsieur legozo la question de
l'urne c'est comment on va gérer votre
portefeuille à partir de là il s'est mis
les pieds dans les plats à peu près tous
les jours que ça soit sur l'immigration
ou sur le troisième lien et monsieur
Legault aurait très bien pu dire comme
il y en avait commencé à en parler au
printemps écouté c'est un problème
complexe on va avoir une grande
conversation nationale là-dessus on va
faire des états de généraux comme si on
parlementaire peu importe la campagne
électorale c'est peut-être pas le
meilleur moment pour parler de tout ça
au lieu de ça il est sauté dans la mêlée
et avec le résultat qu'on a vu monsieur
Legault a pas la comment dire la finesse
je trouve de pour discuter avec toutes
les nuances qu'il faut d'une question
aussi complexe dans le feu d'une
campagne électorale et à partir de là il
y aurait pas dû se lancer là-dedans
Chantal est-ce que quand il va payer le
prix ou pas parce que là finalement il a
pris une décision alors ça a été pour
réparer les dégâts là amenez monsieur
voulait à présenter des excuses puis à
faire une tournée d'entrevue d'excuses
et lui de dire ben écoutez dans un
prochain mandat ce sera pas un ministre
de l'Immigration monsieur boulet est-ce
que c'est suffisant pour réparer les
dommages
probablement qu'il payera pas une grosse
facture lundi
le Dialo pour reprendre l'expression et
pas mal pris en ce qui est très au
résultat de sélection au début de la
campagne la CAC avait probablement
désespoir de reprendre ou de prendre
plus de terrain à Montréal je pense que
là dessus c'est du genre de déclaration
qui est pas et contrairement aux gens
qui font juste aligner des colonnes
c'est quand même important pour le
gouvernement ou le parti qui forme un
gouvernement au Québec d'avoir une
représentation à Montréal c'est c'est
pas sain d'avoir
un gouvernement qui représente tout sauf
Montréal mais ça c'est un mais là où il
se fait du tort c'est dans sa capacité
d'avoir des appuis pour ce qui laisse
faire accomplir en rapatriement pouvoir
sur l'immigration parce que je dois vous
dire que avoir la campagne électorale
faudra pas trop compter sur de parties
conservateurs fédérales qui veut gagner
une élection dans les banlieues de
Toronto dans les banlieues de Vancouver
très diversifiés pour se faire le
porte-voix des revendications de
François Legault je pense qu'on est plus
là avec la campagne électorale là-dessus
bah lui coûter du capital politique dans
les négociations qui traitant avoir avec
le gouvernement Justin Trudeau vous
venez de parler de l'important d'avoir
une représentativité de Montréal au sein
du gouvernement mais est-ce que c'est
important aussi d'en avoir une pour tous
les partis à partir du moment où ils ont
atteint le seuil de 15% d'intention de
votre c'est du moins ce que pense
il abordait ce sujet là aujourd'hui on
va l'écouter
si des voix ne se font pas attendre dans
le Parlement là où les choses se
décident elles font elles se font
souvent entendre dans la rue je pense
pas qu'il va y avoir de soulèvement mais
à l'approche de ce vote là je réitère
même pour des adversaires avec qui j'ai
pas de points en commun ou presque pas
je réitère qu'on a besoin d'opposition
forte
et surtout il en a rajouté monsieur
Saint-Pierre flamandon en disant j'ai
très peu en commun avec Éric Zem mais je
pense que si un parti obtient 15% il
mérite d'être entendu à l'Assemblée
nationale sinon ce n'est pas légitime
tour de table là-dessus en commençant
par vous Stéphanie
mais si on avait un système de scrutin
qui était entièrement proportionnelle
avec 15% des voix un parti comme comme
celui de Monsieur Duhem ou celui de
comme le Parti québécois aurait
peut-être une vingtaine de députés à peu
près et là dans avec le scrutin le mode
de scrutin qu'on a ils vont peut-être
avoir zéro un deux trois alors c'est sûr
que ça crée une énorme distorsion le
fait d'avoir cinq parties ça nuit aux
parties qui sont plus petits qui ont
moins de votes et évidemment ça favorise
beaucoup la CAQ donc est-ce que est-ce
que c'est normal est-ce que c'est singes
je ne pense pas mais une réforme du mode
de scrutin évidemment ça a été ça a été
écarté
il reste à voir il y a quand même des
probabilités que Monsieur Paul
Saint-Pierre l'abond soit élu dans sa
circonscription pardon surtout que
évidemment il y a eu un retrait du
candidat de la candidate
pour pour Monsieur dum il faudra voir
aussi mais moi je pense que avec la
campagne que Monsieur Saint-Pierre la
Mondon a mené très positif certainement
qui mériteraient un siège il y aurait un
apport
on se rappelle tous de monsieur Legault
vous savez la question de revoir la
méthode de vote proportionnelle ou pas
s'intéresse juste quelques intellectuels
mais est-ce que c'est pas justement la
campagne à 5 parties qui fait en sorte
que ça remet ce dossier là à
l'avant-plan et là les gens voient elle
est où la distorsion
ça m'étonne toujours d'entendre monsieur
Legault quand tu dis ça parce qu'à
l'époque où il y avait signé son entente
il trouvait pas que c'est une question
qui intéressait juste les intellectuels
là il trouvait que ça donne important et
encore aujourd'hui je l'entendais
réfléchir à voix haute sur les mérites
quand même d'un système il sent que les
gens voient un problème et quand tu as
parlé il y a deux trois jours de
collaboration avec les autres parties
c'est parce qu'il voit bien qu'il y a un
problème de représentativité et que au
lendemain de l'élection les gens vont
commencer à s'en apercevoir alors j'ai
comme l'impression que l'histoire du
mode de scrutin il va il va continuer à
traîner ça comme ça
peut-être
une réaction je me souviens encore
François Legault qui disait je ne ferai
pas un Justin Trudeau de moi-même ce
qu'il a fait c'était la conclusion de
panel ce soir merci à vous trois d'avoir
été avec nous au revoir au revoir au
revoir